a todos
é com muito gosto que estamos hoje
queria partilhar este nosso projecto
a gente é um projecto que mexeu em 2008
somando dois jovens ambiciosos e que
tiveram a audácia am dos pinhais e de
pensar que através das artes marciais
chinesas através dos seus conhecimentos
de psicologia do desporto poderiam
contribuir para a formação de villas e
quem sabe que há regras desportivas e
esse é o nosso sonho no início do ano
estávamos nós de saber que iríamos
chegar até que sou só eu já até o
trabalho que desenvolvemos até agora a
performance que vão ver aqui hoje é o
resultado de anos de trabalho
apesar de alguns dos nossos atletas que
estão cá hoje serem bastantes jovens no
entanto já vem desenvolvendo levada há
alguns anos e é o resultado de um
trabalho diário que da nossa parte e
exija assistência respeito pelo time de
cada um e por sempre em primeiro lugar
a vida de cada aluno ea vida de cada
atleta só assim é que nós conseguimos
depois de todas estas considerações e
todos estes cuidados obter resultados da
aprendizagem obter resultados de
aprendizagem de valores e depois indo
técnica de capacidades físicas e
conseguir que tudo isso seja projetado
na vida lá fora e seja aplicado no seu
dia a dia
e resumindo de forma muito breve este é
o foco do nosso trabalho diário é cuidar
da vida de quem está conosco todos os
dias nós temos muita consciência do
impacto que temos e do tempo que
passamos com os nossos alunos e com os
nossos atletas e do quanto isso tem que
ser muito bem aproveitado porque há
muito para construir minha vida
principalmente os mais jovens contar um
pouco tempo que temos todos hoje e
principalmente tá um pouco tempo que eu
está em porque as atividades que têm nas
suas vidas são imensas
a pressão para os resultados escolares é
grande e depois e eventualmente alguma
opção para resultados desportivos e
portanto considerar que eles têm que
estar em primeiro lugar é é nossa base
do trabalho e ela conjuga as artes
marciais chinesas princípios da cultura
chinesa e princípios associados à
pedagogia dentro das artes marciais
chinesas e depois princípios da
psicologia e no desporto é com muito
gosto vamos partilhar um pouquinho do
trabalho do nosso trabalho atletas das
forças nacionais que competem lá fora e
que competem em iwate onde antes do
nosso projeto não existe em portugal
isso é muito muito orgulho para nós e
garante os que para ele também é um
gosto enorme estar aqui poderem
partilhar o trabalho que fazem todos os
dias
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ae
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah ah ah
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]